google acquired stackdriver back in 2014
and the suite of operations tools in
google cloud has come a very long way
since then
today cloud monitoring is built right
into the cloud console
and i'm here to show you how to set up
and use monitoring in your cloud
projects
this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
with the integration of monitoring
features into the cloud console you'll
notice that the stackdriver brand is
gone
but the functionality you've come to
depend on isn't changing you'll still be
able to use all the features you're used
to
let's take a look at those and what's
new
let's start by selecting monitoring from
the products menu instead of opening the
stackdriver ui in a new window
you get a new better design ui right in
the console
note that you can still select or
configure the workspace in this new ui
the concept of workspaces and using them
to aggregate monitoring data across
multiple projects
hasn't changed workspaces and their host
projects are still how you create and
retain monitoring configuration data
let's take a look at the core features
of cloud monitoring we'll start by
setting up a vm and deploying a web
server on it
from there we'll install the monitoring
agent set up an uptime check
and configure a dashboard to show us the
health of our new service we'll put the
link to the full steps in the episode
notes so you can easily follow along
start by creating a compute engine
virtual machine by going to the products
menu and selecting compute engine
from there create a new instance you can
leave most options at default
once the instance is created use the ssh
functionality in the console to open a
secure terminal session to your new vm
we're going to use this to do two things
install the apache web server
and install the monitoring agent first
run sudo apt-get update
and sudo apt-get install apache php to
get the latest package versions and
install apache
then run these two commands to download
and install the monitoring agent
now that the environment is set up we're
ready to configure cloud monitoring
let's first create an uptime check
that'll monitor our web service
and potentially notify us if there's a
problem from the products menu select
monitoring and go to uptime checks
create a new one you'll need to get the
machine's external ip address to enter
the target here
test the check before saving it to make
sure everything is configured properly
note that this ip address is ephemeral
by default and may change
you may want to assign a static ip
address to this machine if this is a
service with external users or consumers
from here let's configure a dashboard so
we can easily visualize the health of
our small service
we can include charts showing us the
availability and performance of our
uptime check
and charts showing us infrastructure
utilization to get a complete picture
go to products select monitoring and
click on dashboards then create a new
dashboard
to add a chart showing uptime check
failures select uptime check url as the
resource
and check passed as the metric filter
the data to just the update check you
just created
and use the count false aggregator to
only show you failures
once you save this chart you can follow
a similar process to add other charts to
your dashboard
you might want to include a chart
showing the performance of your service
as reflected by the uptime check latency
metric
you can also include charts showing
resource utilization of your
infrastructure
looking at metrics like cpu utilization
of your vm is a great place to start
one of the new features that's been made
available with this release is the
dashboards api
you'll now be able to automate the
creation of dashboards in your
workspaces
and generally automate more of your
monitoring setup we'll come back to
dashboard and monitoring automation in
future episodes
once your monitoring is set up you'll
probably want alerted to get notified if
the service goes down
since we've already set up the
monitoring we can create a new alerting
policy by clicking on it in the menu
we can set our uptime check as the
resource type and set the metric to make
sure that it passes
then set up an email notification if you
want to see more details on how to set
it up
check out the link below to the earlier
video we did on alerting
that wraps up our internet cloud
monitoring and our tour of its new
integration in the cloud
console we've created a service
configure the dashboard to show us its
health
and set up alerting to let us know if it
has any issues you are now ready to
start using cloud monitoring in your own
environment
i hope you are as excited about the
future of cloud monitoring and these new
features as i am
that's it for this episode come back
next time when we take a look at what's
new
in cloud logging this is the stackdoctor
stay healthy out there
you